[Music]
naomi judd's daughters ashley and winona
judd announced their mother's death in a
statement saying today we sisters
experienced a tragedy we lost our
beautiful mother to the disease of
mental illness
we are shattered we are navigating
profound grief and
know that as we loved her she was loved
by her public we are in unknown
territory
[Music]
the statement from naomi's publicist
said her husband of 32 years larry
strickland will not be making any
further statements adding naomi judd's
family requests privacy during this
heartbreaking time no additional
information will be released at this
time my mama loved you so much
and she appreciated your love for her
and i'm sorry that she couldn't hang on
until today
sadly the judds were inducted into the
country hall of fame a day after naomi's
death her daughters were there for the
emotional medallion ceremony celebrating
their mother i didn't prepare anything
tonight because i knew mom would
probably talk the most
um
i'm gonna make this fast because my
heart's broken
and
i feel so blessed and it's a very
strange dynamic
to be this broken in this blessed